incredibly Sony owns a film rights to
more than 900 Marvel Comics characters a
whole laundry list of spider-man
properties that the studio plans have
spent off into their own cinematic
universe here's the story behind every
movie planned for Sony spider-verse the
first entry in Sony's elaborate plan for
an interconnected world of spider-man
based films was 2018 blockbuster venom
critics were split on the quality of
this fairly odd film which often played
like a dark mismatched buddy comedy in
which both roles were played by the same
guy at the same time more important to
Sony however is the fact that venom
gross 850 million dollars at the
worldwide box office no I ain't
please film goers clearly have an
appetite for venom so naturally the
character will return in venom - and
that might not be the end of it either
star Sam Hardy mentioned in 2018 that
he's contracted for a whole trilogy of
venom movies meanwhile venom
screenwriter Jeff Pinkner
confirmed to discussing film in December
that he was already at work on the
second installment and in August 2019
Andy Serkis signed up to direct as for a
release date venom to is highly likely
to be the mysterious and titled marble
sequel that sonia's penciled in for
October 2022 years after the debut of
the first film while working to cure
himself of a deadly blood disorder
scientist Michael Morbius manages
accidentally signs himself into becoming
a vampire using his scientific expertise
and his newly acquired array of
supernatural powers the character
quickly found some success as a tortured
antihero
fighting his lust for blood Bob bringing
vampiric justice to the night first
announced in 2017 production of Morbius
began in February 2019
daniel espinosa will direct from a
script by Matz's Amma and Burke Sharples
the creative minds behind Netflix's
recent lost in space reboots and 2014
straggler untold Oscar winner Jared Leto
stars as the bloodthirsty protagonist
while Matt Smith co-stars as his friends
and fellow vampire loxias Crone Morpheus
his movie theaters on July 31st 2020
Felicia Hardy also known as the Black
Cats has been a recurring foe and
romantic interest for Peter Parker ever
since her first appearance an amazing
spider-man issue 194 a notorious cat
burglar
Black Cats has the power to manipulate
the powers of probability and luck she
made a brief out of costume appearance
an amazing spider-man
and hasn't yet been suited up on the big
screen initially Sony announced a black
cat will be getting a team-up movie with
fellow occasional spider-man allies
silver sable tentatively titled silver
and black and set to be directed by Gina
Prince bite wood Sony pulled the project
from its release calendar in 2018 in
favor of solo movies for the two heroes
according to Variety Prince both wood
will likely no longer direct but will
stay on as a producer for both
individual movies as for her
replacements all that's been reported is
that Sony really wants to go for a
female director the other half of the
canceled so from black project silver
sable is also headed to the movies with
her own announced solo film when she
first showed up an amazing spider-man
issued 265 silver sable appeared about
as 80s that you could get without
actually starting a glam pop band she's
an assassin and mercenary from Eastern
Europe who wields guns knives and
various accouterments with deadly
accuracy like many characters in the
spider-man mythos
she also changes allegiances pretty
frequently acting as both friend and foe
to the friendly neighborhood wall
crawler this is another project with few
details to report at the moment as there
have been real hints to anyone who might
be involved
apart from Gina Prince both words
position as producer Kraven the hunter
first popped up in amazing spider-man
issue 15 all the way back in 1964 in
fact he goes back so far that he was
even a member of the original sinister
six making him the oldest marble carrots
are currently projected to get his own
spider-verse movie a Russian expat with
a unique flair for clothes made out of
lion faces Kraven is a big-game hunter
obsessed with proving that he can kill
anything and in particular spider-man
well these guys come from
unfortunately backstory on the character
is just about all we have on Sony's
Kraven the hunter movie not a lot is
known about the upcoming film adaptation
except that the equalizer - and Jack
Reacher never go back right Sir Richard
wank was hired to write the script back
in August 2018 a couple of months later
wank tease a very special appearance in
the film claiming in an interview with
discussing film that Kraven will come
face to face with spider-man himself
Sony isn't just planning on bringing the
heavy hitters to the spider-verse though
they've also got plans for some of
Marvel's more obscure spider-man
characters Cindy moon is actually
appeared briefly in the MCU
but her comic alter-ego selcas yet to be
explored on film in the comics a retcon
explained that Cindy was bitten by the
radioactive spider s pizza and ended up
with very similar powers little
development has been reported on a
project aside from the major
announcement in 2018 that longtime Sony
producer and spider poverty Shepherd Amy
Pascal was attached to produce pascal's
2019 departure from the company however
has thrown the project into doubt then
you've got jackpots a scientist mom and
all-around super-strong crime-fighting
bus the details behind the purported
jackpot movie are pretty mysterious with
Sony still in the process of finding a
screenwriter to take on so it's safe to
assume it'll be a while before jackpot
hits theaters finally there's a rumor
swirling around that Spike Lee is in
line to direct Sony's upcoming might
watch movie with Luke Cage showrunner Jo
hidari coker said to be a top candidate
for writing duties but that's all about
anyone knows about that one too
spider-man into the spider versus a
truly special movie it's won an Oscar
for Best Animated Feature outranked
every other spider-man movie and Rotten
Tomatoes and their nearly 200 million
dollars other domestic box-office the
world clearly wants more trips through
time and space with Miles Morales and
his friends and luckily a sequel is
indeed in the works Sony announced big
plans for the animated sector of US
Marvel slate in November 2018 before
into the spider-verse that even hit
theaters Avatar The Last Airbender
veteran Joaquim dos Santos has signed on
to direct the film with Wonder Woman
1984 and Zombieland - writer David
Callaham handling the script that's off
see you'll have to say that we going
spider-man into the spider-verse was
particularly noteworthy for spotlighting
a biracial teen superhero in Miles
Morales alongside a standout female
leading Gwen Stacy and now the latter is
set to get her own animated spin-off
before into the spider-verse hit
theatres Sony announced they had started
work on a film about three generations
of spider women spider-gwen will return
from the first movie assisted in her
adventures by another Spider Woman
Jessica drew and silk Sony has hired
back Smith to fend the screenplay and DC
animation veteran Lauren Montgomery to
direct but more details have yet to be
confirmed check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]